Metode sample-based quantum diagonalization atau SQD singkatnya adalah algoritma hybrid quantum klasik seperti Krylov
quantum diagonalization KQD, seperti VQE, dan banyak lainnya. Dalam menggunakan algoritma hybrid seperti itu,
mungkin berguna untuk memikirkan di mana setiap algoritma memanfaatkan komputasi kuantum dan klasik. Ingat bahwa VQE membuat state pada
quantum circuit menggunakan parameter yang dioptimalkan secara klasik. Dalam kasus itu, state itu sendiri berada di komputer kuantum. Meskipun
mendapatkan state target adalah proses yang menggabungkan komputasi klasik dan kuantum.
Nilai ekspektasi dari operator dihitung menggunakan pengukuran kuantum.
Tapi beberapa penggabungan suku secara klasik juga diperlukan.
Sebaliknya, SQD menggunakan komputer kuantum untuk menghasilkan subspace yang berguna di mana Hamiltonian atau operator lain bisa
diproyeksikan. Hamiltonian kemudian didiagonalisasi sepenuhnya secara klasik untuk menemukan state target. Misalkan kita punya
masalah yang relevan bagi sains atau industri yang bisa dirumuskan sebagai masalah eigensolver pada matriks dengan n baris dan
n kolom. Misalkan lebih lanjut bahwa n cukup besar sehingga diagonalisasi klasik yang eksak bukan merupakan pilihan.
Jelas akan menguntungkan jika kita bisa mengurangi dimensi matriks kita sambil mempertahankan semua fitur relevan dari ground state. Memang, itulah
tujuan dari banyak pendekatan eigensolver aproksimasi, termasuk metode Krylov klasik. Mari kita asumsikan bahwa kita tahu cukup banyak tentang masalah kita untuk membuat
tebakan yang cukup bagus tentang bentuk ground state, tapi tidak cukup untuk menyelesaikan masalah secara langsung. Dalam
kasus itu, kita bisa membuat banyak pengukuran dari aproksimasi yang cukup baik dari ground state target. Hasil dari
pengukuran ini memberi kita subspace dari computational basis states yang mengandung semua komponen relevan dari
ground state kita. Memproyeksikan ke subspace tersebut akan menghasilkan matriks yang lebih kecil yang masih mengandung derajat kebebasan yang relevan.
Alur kerja untuk ini adalah sebagai berikut. Kamu mulai dengan memilih ansatz yang baik.
Lebih tepatnya, pilih ansatz yang support-nya bertepatan dengan support dari state target. Kita akan membahas apa tepatnya yang
dimaksud dengan itu. Berikutnya, ukur state dalam computational basis seperti yang dilakukan dengan Qiskit sampler primitive.
Kemudian, gunakan hasil sampling untuk mendefinisikan subspace yang mengandung ground state.
Kemudian, proyeksikan matriksmu ke subspace tersebut. Terakhir, diagonalisasi matriks terproyeksi yang lebih kecil secara klasik.
Mari kita urai setiap langkah ini, dengan memperhatikan khusus pada pendefinisian subspace.
Di seluruh komputasi kuantum, memilih ansatz yang baik selalu kritis. Dalam kasus SQD, pilihan ansatz kamu
akan menentukan computational basis states apa yang mungkin diukur dalam sampling.
Ground state sejati bisa diekspresikan sebagai superposisi dari beberapa subset computational basis states. Subset itu
disebut support dari ground state. Untuk mendapatkan estimasi yang baik dari ground state dan energinya, ansatz kamu
harus memiliki proyeksi non-nol ke computational basis states dalam support dari ground state.
Diagram ini merepresentasikan ruang yang direntang oleh semua state yang mungkin pada jumlah qubit yang digunakan. Kita ingin
ansatz dengan support yang mengandung support dari ground state sejati.
Pertimbangkan contoh sistem yang sangat kecil dengan ground state s_ground = 8 kali
state 100 ditambah 6 kali state 001.
Ini memiliki support yang terdiri dari dua vektor 100 dan 001. Katakanlah ansatz-nya berbentuk s_ansatz1 = A kali
state 100 ditambah B kali state 010 ditambah C kali state 001. Sehingga
support-nya adalah himpunan tiga vektor 100, 010, dan 001, yaitu superset dari
support dari ground state. Ini adalah ansatz yang baik.
Sekarang bayangkan sebaliknya kita memilih ansatz berbentuk s_ansatz2 = a kali
state 110 ditambah b kali state 011.
Ini memiliki support yang terdiri dari dua vektor 110 dan 011 yang tidak memiliki tumpang tindih dengan support dari ground
state. Ini adalah ansatz yang buruk.
Perhatikan bahwa kita tidak harus mensyaratkan ansatz menjadi aproksimasi yang baik dari ground state. Ansatz bisa
memiliki support yang jauh lebih besar atau koefisiennya bisa sangat berbeda antara ansatz dan ground state sejati dan masih bekerja dengan baik.
Pada tahap ini, kita telah menggunakan ansatz yang termotivasi dengan baik untuk membuat komputer kuantum mengadopsi state yang mirip dengan state target
kita. Yang ditampilkan di sini adalah ansatz unitary coupled Jastrow atau UCJ yang sangat berguna dalam kimia kuantum.
Sekarang kita ingin mengukur state sistem untuk mendapatkan bitstring yang mendeskripsikan state yang runtuh dari setiap
qubit. Ingat bahwa estimasi Hamiltonian seperti dalam VQE memerlukan banyak pengukuran kuantum. Ini sebagian untuk
mengurangi ketidakpastian dan sebagian karena jumlah kelompok Pauli yang komutasi yang membentuk Hamiltonian.
Dalam metode sampling, kamu masih perlu banyak pengukuran, tapi alasannya berbeda. Sekarang, kita memerlukan banyak pengukuran untuk secara efektif mengambil sampel dari
banyak computational basis states yang terlibat dalam state kuantum yang sangat entangled. Dalam SQD, bitstring yang disampel bersesuaian
dengan konfigurasi sistem yang disimulasikan. Jika sistem yang dipelajari tunduk pada batasan absolut seperti
hukum kekekalan dalam fisika atau kimia, maka sebagian besar state yang diukur akan valid. Tapi beberapa bitstring
yang disampel bersesuaian dengan konfigurasi yang tidak valid atau tidak fisikal karena noise dan kesalahan. Sebuah proses yang disebut
configuration recovery bertujuan untuk memurnikan sampel yang berisik ini menjadi sekumpulan konfigurasi yang lebih akurat.
Proses ini melibatkan pembuatan konfigurasi baru dengan membalik bit individual secara probabilistik berdasarkan
rata-rata occupancy orbital dan jumlah partikel yang diketahui.
Konfigurasi yang telah dimurnikan kemudian digunakan untuk merentang subspace untuk proyeksi dan diagonalisasi Hamiltonian,
yang secara iteratif meningkatkan fidelitas representasi state kuantum.
Mari kita lihat contoh yang sangat sederhana dari configuration recovery untuk memahami artinya. Misalkan kita mengukur
sistem kuantum dengan empat qubit yang merepresentasikan empat orbital molekul dan mendapatkan bitstring berikut dari
prosesor kuantum. Setiap bitstring merepresentasikan occupancy dari sebuah orbital. Satu untuk
terisi, nol untuk tidak terisi. Qiskit menggunakan notasi di mana qubit yang paling tidak signifikan berada di sebelah kanan.
WEBVTT
Misalnya, 1010 menunjukkan bahwa orbital 1 dan 3 terisi. Pengukuran-pengukuran
ini dipilih hanya untuk tujuan pedagogis. Occupancy yang dihasilkan mungkin tidak cocok dengan sistem fisikal. Dalam konteks fisikal,
seringkali sistem memiliki jumlah partikel total yang diketahui. Mungkin juga ada hukum kekekalan lain yang
bisa kamu manfaatkan untuk menentukan fisikalitas dari state yang diukur. Agar konkret, mari kita asumsikan sistem kita
diketahui memiliki jumlah partikel total n=2. Ini memberi tahu kita jumlah total angka satu yang seharusnya muncul dalam label state
kita, yang disebut batasan Hamming weight.
Namun, beberapa konfigurasi yang diukur melanggar batasan ini. State 1010 secara fisikal valid. Tapi state 1110
memiliki terlalu banyak partikel dan state semua nol memiliki terlalu sedikit partikel. Nol
sebenarnya. Pelanggaran ini bisa disebabkan oleh noise dalam sistem atau kesalahan dalam pengukuran. Kita perlu cara untuk kembali
ke konfigurasi yang masuk akal secara fisikal setidaknya secara aproksimasi.
Ini disebut configuration recovery.
Untuk mengoreksi sampel yang berisik, kita membalik bit secara probabilistik dalam konfigurasi yang tidak valid berdasarkan rata-rata
occupancy orbital yang dirata-ratakan dari konfigurasi yang valid.
Occupancy orbital adalah nilai ekspektasi dari operator bilangan yang bekerja pada setiap orbital. Ini diestimasi dan
dimurnikan secara self-consistent menggunakan state yang dihasilkan dari SQD. Mari kita lihat orbital 2 misalnya. Dalam dua dari
empat konfigurasi yang valid, orbital 2 terisi. Ini memberi kita occupancy yang diharapkan sebesar 0,5.
Kita melakukan hal yang sama untuk ketiga orbital lainnya. Sekarang kita kembali ke konfigurasi yang tidak valid 1110. Kita bisa membalik salah satu
bit dari 1 menjadi nol untuk menghasilkan konfigurasi yang valid. Tapi bit mana yang harus kita balik? Salah satu cara untuk memutuskan adalah
melalui deviasi occupancy setiap orbital dari rata-rata yang baru saja kita hitung.
Di sini kita melihat bahwa perbedaan terbesar ada pada occupancy orbital satu. Jadi kita mungkin berharap bahwa bit satu seharusnya
dibalik dari satu menjadi nol. Tentu saja, orbital 2 tidak jauh ketinggalan. Dan selalu mungkin, meskipun tidak mungkin, bahwa
state yang diukur ini adalah hasil dari beberapa kesalahan pada state yang sama.
Hanya memilih deviasi terbesar dari rata-rata untuk semua state yang tidak valid bukanlah yang optimal. Sebaliknya, bit dibalik
secara probabilistik dengan probabilitas yang merupakan fungsi dari perbedaan yang ditunjukkan di sini. Misalkan dalam
kasus ini kita memang mengubah bit yang paling berbeda dari occupancy rata-rata. Jadi 1110 menjadi 1010. Kita akan melakukan
proses yang sama untuk pilihan yang tidak valid lainnya. Katakanlah dalam kasus ini kita berakhir dengan membalik bit satu dan tiga.
Setelah proses koreksi ini, kita memiliki sekumpulan konfigurasi baru yang mungkin terlihat seperti ini.
Menggunakan himpunan yang telah dimurnikan ini, kita bisa memperbarui rata-rata occupancy orbital untuk meningkatkan fidelitas. Dalam kasus kita, occupancy
yang baru adalah ini.
Proses recovery iteratif ini memastikan bahwa pengukuran yang berisik disaring menjadi konfigurasi yang bermakna secara fisikal,
meningkatkan akurasi aproksimasi eigenstate dalam SQD. Qiskit add-on SQD memiliki beberapa tools yang
akan sangat berguna dalam proses ini. Jika kita sudah melakukan pekerjaan yang baik dalam mengambil sampel state dalam support dari ground state sejati
dari sistem, maka kita seharusnya bisa melihat hanya bagian-bagian dari Hamiltonian yang bekerja pada subspace ini
dan masih mendapatkan ground state dan energi yang baik. Dalam contoh 4 qubit yang sangat sederhana, awalnya ada 2^4 atau 16
state yang mungkin dari sistem. Menggunakan kombinasi sampling dan configuration recovery, kita mereduksi ini
menjadi tiga state dalam subspace yang kita minati. Tiga state yang kita harapkan membentuk support dari ground state sejati.
Kita sekarang memproyeksikan Hamiltonian penuh kita ke subspace tersebut. Yaitu kita membuat matriks M dari kolom vektor dari
subspace yang disampel dan dipulihkan dan yang analognya M dagger dari baris dan kita mengalikan M dagger H M
secara piktorial. Ini berarti mengambil elemen matriks dalam baris dan kolom yang bersesuaian dengan state dalam
subspace yang disampel dan dipulihkan. Baris dan kolom yang di-highlight adalah yang bersesuaian dengan subspace kita. Dan
kotak yang di-highlight lebih gelap di mana mereka tumpang tindih adalah elemen yang kita simpan untuk matriks terproyeksi baru kita.
Sekarang bahwa kita telah memilih subspace yang diminati, kita bisa mendiagonalisasi matriks ini di komputer klasik
menggunakan solver standar. Jika ground state sejati sepenuhnya terdiri dari state dalam subspace kita,
diagonalisasi ini seharusnya menghasilkan ground state dan energi ground state yang benar. Jika kita hanya memiliki sebagian besar support dari ground state,
kita mungkin mendekatinya. Setelah kita mendapatkan ground state untuk Hamiltonian terproyeksi ini, kita memiliki state yang sangat
berguna untuk menghitung rata-rata occupancy dari setiap orbital.
Sebelumnya, occupancy kita dihitung dari state yang kita sampel menggunakan ansatz yang kita harapkan akan membantu
kita mendekati ground state. Tapi tidak ada jaminan bahwa rata-rata occupancy setiap orbital dari sampling tersebut bersesuaian dengan occupancy
dalam state dengan energi terendah. Mari kita kembali ke awal. Kita memiliki sampling dari computational states. Kita menggunakan configuration recovery
untuk mengoreksi yang secara fisikal tidak valid. Kemudian kita menghitung rata-rata occupancy orbital menggunakan semuanya.
Ground state mungkin hanya mencakup sebagian dari mereka. Ground state dari Hamiltonian terproyeksi ini mungkin bukan ground state sejati
dari sistem asli kita, tapi ini adalah state dengan energi terendah yang bisa dibuat menggunakan superposisi apa pun dari
state yang dipulihkan dalam subspace kita. Occupancy orbital dari state ini akan menghasilkan energi yang lebih kecil atau sama dengan
energi dari occupancy yang diperoleh dari ruang yang dipulihkan. Jadi occupancy ini adalah estimasi yang lebih baik dari
occupancy ground state kita. Kita bisa mengulang proses configuration recovery menggunakan occupancy baru ini dan kita bisa mengiterasi
ini sampai kriteria konvergensi kita terpenuhi. Sample-based quantum diagonalization lebih cepat dibandingkan
algoritma near-term lainnya seperti VQE. Ini lebih scalable dan lebih robust terhadap noise dan kesalahan dalam sampling. Ini
masih memerlukan bahwa kita menyiapkan ansatz yang baik dengan proyeksi yang besar di bawah support dari ground state sejati dari sistem kita. Jika sama sekali tidak ada yang diketahui
tentang ground state sejati kita, SQD mungkin perlu digunakan bersama dengan metode lain untuk pertama-tama mempelajari tentang
ground state dan mendekatinya secara iteratif.
SQD memainkan peran kritis dalam rangkaian algoritma hybrid klasik-kuantum yang sedang berkembang dan merupakan salah satu
pendorong terbesar menuju komputasi kuantum yang berguna.